it said that if we can make a start
are you happy to take the fire
evacuation notices red we have received
analogies in the office from from
countless losses butcher and capsule
Eric so in terms of process I'll need
someone to to move emotion nominating
someone to charity ever meeting Alison
and a second death and we'll need to
vote on that counselor was a sure I
propose my school for this meeting in
future any one second that this painting
so could we please have a show of hands
okay thank you if I could hand over to
you please make us feel like as us on
your set the vice-chairman can't make it
either so we need a proposal so who will
be vice chair for this meeting only
cares mature thanks very much
this meeting only is nice second members
in favor
members item to substitute members
that our members attending minutes of a
meeting held on 26 February 2009 Dean
everybody in the grievant Teresa you've
declarations of interest no right a
slight change to the agenda the next
item is in fact item 11 on the agenda
the annual government statement 2018-19
this is the main because barely I think
you'll be taking it things been linked
to the young is recommended because that
is the main report that we've got to
look at yeah we recognize that the you
don't it's quite heavy tonight there's a
number of reports to get through so we
just suggested slightly prioritizing in
this a few reports that we absolutely
need to sort of discuss and agree
tonight obviously willing to get through
them and discuss them all but and we
just wanted to have those sort of the
other key ones coming first and if
anyone's got any objections waiting to
do that
with ostrich happy to do so but I don't
agree don't cooperate by doing when it
comes to choosing okay great
but good at it speak on the report
please thank you and yeah so the purpose
of this report is to present to members
the wrong annual government statements
for the country in 2018 90 members would
be aware that we are required by the
accounts and audit regulations to
present an ATS to members each year the
format of the statement has been
prepared in accordance with the local
government framework and produced by so
far we have changed the format of the
annual government's that statement
slightly this year so that it more
directly correlates to the principle set
out in in code of good practice so the
seven principles that we have to adhere
to us and if as a council to show that
we were demonstrating good governance
and we set out in the annual balance
statement how the council would here's
to each of those principles in turn so
yeah members are basically asked to
approve that the annual government
statement is endorsed but also that if
there's any slight changes that need to
be made between now and the final
accounts being published because this
forms part of the final accounts are
brought to the next audit committee in
July that any slight changes can be
delegated to the chairman of the audit
committee to approve before that next
Audit Committee meeting in July so I'm
also planning to go through in great
detail and the actual annual governance
statement itself but I'm happy to take
any questions that members make up can I
ask members before anybody asks any
questions they because we've got so much
to get through that they keep their
questions printed sides of this country
thank you
you want this president one of the
things on the question of NCIC to return
to the first paragraph he says we're
hosting
well Chris there was a huge interest
issue for a week yeah there are there
are some resilience issues with the
fundamental ICT infrastructure but the
key controls around access rights and
other things above are adequate so there
are three pieces resilient to things in
terms of the network falls over but
they're known problems that we are
seeking to resolve but we've actually
had another priority come in and do a
piece of work to identify where the real
problems exist and then it's been
previous report of this committee that
we are we're well aware of ICD problems
document in yangon state you actually
think there is some provision we've been
here yeah I mean when you're talking
about things like safe answers the other
Authority
why completely I can confirm it he's now
complete with that that report back
school because it is that these
communicators were brought together
probably we have that report so
essentially this is done in a few weeks
any in the past that we just have reason
to receive that report so I can now
confirm you know and have had that
report when we will be addressing the
realest today's day and you were saying
that by today's date we haven't started
which is not you know we haven't had
that the detailed site of the report at
this stage so as we said this is a draft
statement in this stage and we could
potentially make a major change but if
there's a significant issue that is
identified through that report basis at
the point of report was which we hadn't
received it so this was presented in
good faith fasting on the information we
had available to us at that time
one quick okay 11:15 bottom business
really small so sorry which paper you're
hosting
last sentence
we
so I think there's a couple of aspects
that we were identified in their
previous years and your governance
statement so in terms of doing further
work on our business continuity and
resilience plans and also again around
IT so we recognize that that's a work in
progress and things aren't perfect at
the moment so it's just recognizing that
there is still for the wrong guy and
work so we're trying to present a fair
and balanced view in in the report so we
accept that there are assurances in
place to manage risk and performance
return or control but there is still
ongoing work in relation to business
resilience and
yeah so I would just refer think - yeah
slightly further one in the report as
well on page I'm just finding yeah
another 24 where we go specifically yes
the top two items in terms of governance
area Samaritan 18 so in nineteen twenty
and so business continuity live in of
ICT and business continuity minutes in
terms of service area of business
continuity plans so it's two specific
actions where we've identified specific
things to be done during an X so this
report is around and the control
measures in place in terms of assurance
governance arrangements and assurances
so it's not specifically around the
finance but as part of those governance
Arrangements we do routinely reports and
updates on the IT project to its
executive isn't it on top of which one
it's easy very active investment fourth
there's a specific project and sort of
update and risk which so that's taken to
those meetings are like believe there's
another one due within the next month or
so but the last one that were supportive
basically showed that the ICT migration
project is on track project realize and
I'm not expecting a position to change
it there that's next reporting
- can we catch the whole yet first
burial I just wanna go back to our CTO
needs to take up questions we talked on
item 6 700 years we don't say you became
official but I'm not on the lava
sections think that's go back this ICT
history unless we raise it all now cause
obviously is something that I've seen
before is something that the executive
mentioned is something she's been termed
e99 four six seven seven on that
exaggerated I remember I don't know
where the detail of this any bizarre on
you can either ask the fish now
acknowledge reinforces that he later I
don't mind but uh it's it was obviously
the problem getting this report was the
problem because we didn't give them the
information was their problem because
they didn't want to do the recall the
first question is what what was the
problem in getting colleagues report and
any lots of places they had problems
making the executives but there's a
problem
so I believe it was treated the
resourcing right arrangements ask their
counsel we commissioned a report from
though is basically quite a change of
personnel and there wasn't quite the
handover we would have anticipated or
hoping for so essentially that was the
holdup in their mission the report to us
in and that there are some key personnel
at recurring after review actually left
the organization was there any delay in
the report from seven counsel on the
system that's not the report we're
referring to yeah no so the work that
was delayed and we have now had
something I believe it's not in as much
detail as perhaps we would have hoped
but again I think that's linked to the
impersonality
organization but it was something it was
outside first
so L don't thinks of godets s all about
the troubleshooter truly foolish because
of those delivery both I don't
understand one wondering September
slightly straight outside that but
somewhat but yeah but yeah we have we
were actively chasing the report and
from from South edge and we were led to
believe we were still going to to
receive it I think after yeah at the
last time of passed we realized a loop
that we and that keep us now had then
left the organization so we're now
looking at alternative options to to
read Commission that report in the level
of detail we acquire so we're going to
sew some online that makes you sound
like the report is not it doesn't meet
requirements that we want to believe
said that already
yeah so therefore I'm not sure we will
second that I could accept that report
which doesn't I see yeah lastly we're
integrating I think much assurance for
on-site yeah yeah I think we've tried to
have that that in the paper
so on the cease that must be Paige
diversity pick around on places that I'm
giving what ain't mentions it and you
said you prefer to the sort of
possibility
are we saying that the report you have
no not detail generally confirms the
first paragraph page seven point nine
Hey without put once you've read equally
change the paragraph I just was wrong to
page 70 and the last sorry
fifteen dudes gonna play sorry Jim
I spoke to Assistant Director for
transformation is small in Valens name
apparently reportedly got identified the
issues that we were pretty much aware of
without any recommendations that's
really why
it's acknowledged that how several
switches were not effective but didn't
come up with any recommendations or
methodologies to improve it and the plan
will be for the assistant director to
seek incremental responses one gets
people in to look at things but just bit
by bit prioritize we know we've gotten
issuance which is gonna get someone to
look at the switches make priorities and
recommendations on that so that possibly
won't be an overall report which we try
to get them south in
bye pal approach deal with issues and
the next and blockage in this area
cigarettes they might be these are more
technical many one people may be the
presents for a while in also he says
there are no significant issues
identified with respective councils in
the house of refractory quite a person
you just made some sweet do something
from talking to elevate most intimate
scene switches to the people in critical
case well they probably are not
significant issues one incident that
they're probably in has even structure
yes
he says they would notice it all they
can't the in-house infrastructure along
they say some nasty issues identified in
respect of counseling housing project in
this report Saunders on living there I
think you say that this could have
changes I think the trainees should be
included in there to say that they've
been these they are significant
yeah I think I think that sentence is
referred to the self-assessment side the
self so the work kind of consider self
similar carried out for the Algerian
progress made in implementing
recommendations following a penetration
test by external contractor at the start
of the 1819 financial years that didn't
identify any significant issues we know
as you say that that those the world
from failures in the server room which
causes issues near on in in the year
which is why we then sought to
Commission this external report to
provide some additional assurances that
that couldn't happen again so that's a
scheme referred to as the report which
we haven't had significant or and we
haven't had the assurances we would have
hoped from perform that report but I
don't think we can say that we until
we've seen the deep flow of that that we
would necessarily need to amend the IDs
to to reflect that but if there is
significant new issues are identified
through that report we would obviously
sorry I'm sorry carry on talking to
report when he says there were no
significant issues identified I'm saying
there were significant issues identified
these are significant is not critical
yeah thank you I think I think the
situation was and I agree he can be read
incorrectly it says there were no
significant issues identified there
should have been a Colin there because
it goes on from resilience in respect to
the council
in-house infrastructure requires
addressing I believe is a case of
punctuation which is causing variety and
he has definitely punctuation it was
important because I don't know for a
fact that we did have properly -
sweeties we didn't have a replacement we
had to go to Southend who fortunately
had a replacement switch which they very
kindly put in place to get us over the
problem so we still like in my opinion
and I guess in the majority of us
opinion there may still be an issue
because we're still using what would I
guess the antiquated equipment and of
course we will be looking to go forward
on that but I believe this would come
down to relate to creator items it's a
LGA which was a cybersecurity
self-assessment and then we had a
penetration test undertaken by external
contractors so it's going to get issues
arising from those two things that's
where this evening NTT wrote it was very
poorly written every maybe by going onto
the report the switches we draft that is
that section then was yes we can draw
people it wasn't it wasn't States that
way the intention of misleading it I
think it just could read more read
that's really saying yeah just just come
in on that as well I think when the term
this is a draft I think that's probably
because again you know what people
highlighting are may be issues that
concern them and again if we don't have
that
full report from Southend if we are
looking that I guess my I'm hearing that
we are going to be taking advice from
another expert agency or source to give
us a report
therefore the report is not complete
because we don't know the answers at
this moment so again I can see what is
being what is being sent so again as
this is a draft I guess that we need to
feed in any new information that comes
in yep we've got a little bit of time
before we have to formally sign this off
as part of the account so as I say this
was rich enough based on information we
had at the time now got experience major
we can add the which will change the
complexion of the report we can add at
that is so yes that's correct
I just want follow-up to that not be
lost one of it in the themes area is
that within the budget there's a hundred
thousand pound for a new server room
potentially is that depending upon this
report does that is that in relation to
the problems here is after something
else with what you don't know yes there
is some budget provision set aside it's
not specifically for the server room but
it was with partly with the that will
read us a server room or budget okay
well I stand corrected if it does
actually say sever a mark
okay so there is no amount of money set
aside we haven't actually suspect out
exactly what that would be spent on but
it was within mind at the bat that
potentially there could be some cost
associated coming out of this would be
able to recognize it as one
especially when he was that effective
cancer a certificate waiting just on
clarification on the issue that we had
beginning of the year I was led to
believe that the situation came over us
not having any email for a week was not
technically it was contractual there was
a problem between the data service so I
don't think so again I think with
slightly stone outside the boundaries of
this committee in terms of what we've
what what would be asked agree in terms
of the annual governor's statement so we
are not seeking to address all of the IT
issues as part of this report we're
looking at the controls and sureties
that are in place to maintain the IT
infrastructure across the organization
so obviously we haven't got the relevant
Assistant Director for ICT here at the
moment so I'll answer the detail
questions and I'm not announcer detail
questions on what caused the issues at
that time because I'm not really placed
Orangemen
yes perhaps these questions can't be
answered in this committee but they
should be brought people forward to the
review committee so we've got a better
understanding I don't think this is the
actual platform for these questioners I
think he's got to be able to go to
review there has already been a report
to the Committee on the app only on the
IC out each other that it doesn't know I
believe it's coming forward again yeah I
know he's only gender in line yeah it's
careful sir perhaps these questions
could be noted and perhaps I'll start we
were I came to my likely tools that we
were using too much of agency staff
before what 723 seems to suggest that we
still use agency staff but we just use a
wider range of agencies is that right
so it's correct that we um we haven't
banned age of the use of agencies when
workers completely it was a particular
issue that was identified and has been
discussed in detail audit committee
previously which was about reaching
potential limits in terms of spend with
an individual suppliers and making sure
we weren't reaching it and future it has
to be you new rules but there isn't an
outright ban on using agency staff
across the organization but we have to
make sure we've done it in the correct
way and follow the procedure so I I
can't answer off the top of my head
exactly how many agencies so the issue
wasn't at that time exactly how many
agency staff we were using it was the
amount of agency style or spend which
had with one particular supplier of
agency staff so I haven't got two hands
that or levels of able to stop when for
now versus what we were boys there and
but I can say that we haven't we're not
reaching the lip te Riu living without
sequence I hire I can request that yeah
thank you very much to Jim
yeah I believe I had the same problem
with planning where we were using one
agency and we exceeded the doodlenet
and ceased using
we didn't have any other agencies about
that moment in time so I think that is
something we do have limits on the
amount we can spend with each agency
well it's yes it's not quite as simple
as having limits with each agency it's
just having a mind of the procurement
regulations which means if you're going
to spend over a certain amount of with
any one supplier you have to make sure
you've done gone through the correct
rules so it depends on the level of
spend but it may be seeking free quotes
but if you're going up to higher levels
instead you may have to do that through
the formal EU procedure or through a
framework agreement so that's looking at
framework agreements is something that
the council's pursuing to make sure that
we've options available to us to procure
agencies often to the DA catch the
spirit can going back to the the whole
wording issue and it raises a kind of
issues I'm not quite sure I understand
what as a sure sign but I'm not quite
sure that we should be mixing up report
that's already going into review with
what we're talking about here I think we
should perhaps keep keep the two we call
the separate and can we be assured that
if the wording that we've talked about
being adjusted if there's anything
further that the Chairman may if they
feel that it makes a substantial change
reconvene this committee if it's if it's
just small stuff as as we've said and
it's wording and one thing another but
that we we will have your assurance and
at that our terms assurance that if we
feel that there are substantial changes
then we will need to call an emergency
meeting obviously if it's just as we
anticipate it would be small beer then
then fine but if it makes fundamental
changes to what we've attentively agreed
here then then we would be we would be
made aware of
yeah so I think I've set up defense camp
had service sometimes the procedures but
if ultimately there was a need for
emergency meeting obviously I think
that's proposal in the advantage of the
committee to to agree that I would want
that as I say that the early into
patient although haven't seen the
details report isn't that there was
anything that was more mentally change
our or our opinion as part of the IDS so
I agree there's policies and technical
wording changes that need to be made in
potentially we could maybe circulate
those to almost the committee to just to
check that everyone's happy with those
but I can't anticipate there will be
such fundamental change that would
require the reconvening of the fact
obviously that's within your romantic
you felt it wasn't there's nothing to
propose we've got me good just actually
it's a genuine thing about all the
reports within this particular agenda
one of the things that I always like to
see is if somebody from outside their
organization but member of the public
but to read them they should understand
and there's an awful lot of jargon an
awful lot of initials in here that
aren't actually explained and I'd like
to see maybe in the future please that
all reports are actually and many of
them are but a lot of them are erecting
if you like preceded by the actual
initials mean so that people can
actually understand you know what
each of those initial with me so you
know that's just one proposal but I
think it's about clarity which is
something we must have certainly with
our members of the public I can't tell
you how many people would actually read
through this report but I still think
it's something we should try to be
cheating yeah I think that's that yeah
because the most sure did you want to
yes
further points the recommendation is it
is proposed committee resolves item one
that they got one everything has to be
signed off yes yeah that's it so we can
resolve that easily point
I'm sorry recommendation number one this
president 30 resolved that the annual
government statement for 2018-19 be
indoors a refer to the managing director
and leader of the council for signature
that of course is subject to the
comments that we have made in this
committee it was great food
we're not sure and item to that
authority be delegated to the chairman
of the Audit Committee to endorse any
changes to the AES following review of
the council's external auditors design
again something to the time comments are
given six is now become number seven
which is external auditor reports
updates to Egypt this report members
with an update relation to the
recommendations 2017
this is a cumulative report and those
were fresh updates at the race if
everything was going to start basic
sport six
I can 6.1 on which become water yes
thank you turn on the point it refers to
a variance let me just find it monthly
up here on the top of six-point-six
variance between the councillor in
relation the underlying definite ledger
down it does say the premise of the
demonstration we search around a 31st of
March but it says safer the work is
required to address these historical
balance does that work been done just
clarify please say that and that work is
still being looked at by our our
technical counter and just give you a
bit of context we've we had to employ
new technical accounts and a couple of
months were a few months ago and
following the departure of the technical
council that prepared last year's
accounts and so her priority has been to
prepare the 18 19 accounts and we've and
she's had a lot of work to do in order
to get up to speed and to ensure that we
are able to hit our 18 19 accounts
deadline so as part of that she has been
looking at the debtors we haven't quite
resolved all of the historic issue
that's referred to in this report but in
terms of materiality that's not going to
materially impact on
as as it didn't last year it's not going
to have a material impact on the 1819
death accounts so although it's not an
issue that needs to be resolved we've
had to prioritize other areas of
preparation for the accounts but it is
something that she will is on her party
lists to pick up and once once we
approach me and prepare the 89th in the
council we are still looking to resolve
it we haven't quite and been out to
unpick the in storage issue yet but we
have fixed issue for this year's
accounts for 1819 so as we say we've got
the correct parameters for this year's
but we haven't quite been over time
people's the prior years at this point
in time Big Show merger stuff what used
to live the materiality so for this year
and for this year's accounts I'm trying
because they have changed it slightly
but it's been a sore hand reserves of
pounds
level so I can get the exactly alike my
idea just one more question on the same
page where it refers to the 80 range
within secretary housing again there was
your maker further inquiries with
sanctuary has that never been resolved
so I slightly update to what's written
on here because there has been a bit of
progress again since the painful is
which and we have now managed to find
the original agreement with sanctuary so
in terms of progress we have we have got
the original documentation and which we
were pipe intimate and find velocities
accounts again there is still a little
bit more work to be done to unpick
actually the transactions that have
happened over the period since sort of
housing stock transferred but again
there's nothing to indicate that there's
any material change from what we
reported in last year's counts and we
have now got a better basis to actually
I think and understand that better so we
are making progress but again there's
still a little bit more work to do yes
are we going to do
documents that we should be holding yeah
so obviously I said just principle a
good practice we should be retaining our
records at least in line with data data
retention policy which is generally in
seven years but where we know
something's got a longer lifespan than
that for example this we should be
holding on to our our key documents
obviously that you know massively
predates my time and a lot of offices
time so it's been a bit difficult to
maybe locate some of those documents but
in terms of electronic storage obviously
we've got better and scope for retaining
documents electronically now than
perhaps paper copies of things in the
past where things may have gone a bit
strangely
thank you oh sorry about castor Hall it
was from one to be fair against the
couple to my favorite question it away
from me so it wasn't that it was
obviously only the vit issue so the
original agreement that century has been
found does that make a reference to
another even French an Aussie yes I
believe validates the expectation we had
that you know the HMRC arrangements and
it all looks in line with what we've
been saying all along so it does
validate the arrangements but at the
same time since it's the financials
we're just working through that right so
he confirms the HMRC has agreed the
scheme yeah I believe so please come
have confirmation yes okay again
obviously the auditors will be looking
at as part of the year and to Council we
expect them to report back when I was
part of the accounts anyway bars will
yeah
thank you very much attention yeah I
think this comes back to the situation I
spoke to you earlier trial or various
things that happen because obviously if
these documents fail we have is there a
procedure and an audit trial for these
various things that are going on these
momentary requirements is there an audit
trail than a process I just like to know
is there yes we've got we've got an
policies and procedures in place around
document retention and we are required
to keep all our key documents and data
for a certain amount of time as I say
that this particular thing around the
vit is going back over 10 years now and
we yeah obviously struggled to locate
that originally so I'm not saying it's
always perfect but yeah obviously we do
have policies and procedures to make
sure that we retain in the relevant
records so yeah we do should have an
audit trail of all our key key financial
documents oh great yeah just come back
this one clearly just put the record I
was on the what has association we have
two or three years a dream lifetime on
it there was some there's some things
which happened
but obviously was only looking for a
memory about what happened there were
people there then regards to the
arrangement with sanctuary 318 that was
done at the time when the stop was he
much apparent association that was
transferred output has an association
interest of severe century some years
ago settled out and two doctors don't
have validity and that place isn't if
any of these actually be posted at
transfer there might be something to
look out more inspecting an altar now
yeah so you say my understanding is
their housing stock transferred to
rupture has association with then
subsequently became sanctuary but I
believe the arrangements with the abuses
a new food yeah different ways don't
follow that I mean they're the
organization with Rochford sat
underneath the local one we took to
Hollister remember the name of you know
that we had locally which was different
from about that sound to sanctuary so
it's a sort of three level sort of thing
but it basically is we sanctuary
personally you can say the overall
controller I don't think there's
probably there hold it was transparent
that yeah further questions
recommendation it is pretty results of
the updates provided in the appended
monitoring sheet in respectively
external auditors recommendations
internal holding an annual report that's
number 12 do those numbers a reasonable
number 17 eternal audit annual report
2018-19 still with you mind clear Thank
You chair and the purpose my hand report
communicative members results of our
work at 2019 19 this together with other
forms of assurance and made me provide
an opinion that counsels arrangements
with governess risk management internal
control internal audit is fundamentally
concerned with evaluating an
organization's management of risks to
evaluate how well these risks could be
managed the internal waters that will
assess the quarterly risk management
processes systems of internal control
and corporal government processes across
all parts of an organization if I can
renowned refer members to Appendix 1 on
page seven point six
you receive from this this appendix
we've completed a large number of audio
gangsters because of widespread rumor
council activities again we have
experienced resource and problems during
the course of the year for the first six
months of the year we only had one
member of staff which was Jim we've now
actually a belt with that resource and
problem and the point to the new member
of staff so for the last six months a
year we were fully staffed and you would
see from the appendix that we've been
made to be a lot chunk of work during
the 1819 corrects the completed
assignments you will see will provide an
assurance rating good adequate or
limited you would know the only one
audit review has received a finisher
Experian Jim in 2019 nineteen and this
is balanced against our twelve a further
12 water group reviews that receive
inadequate or good rating no significant
concerns were highlighted irrespective
of audits of the council's key financial
systems these systems are fundamental to
the robustness of the council's overall
controlled environment we also carried
out my further for like such reviews all
know though that assessment was provided
we made recommendations to address
control issues you all further know the
appendix to will provide the new details
of the audits we completed since the
last committee back in February 2009
so my assessment my opinion from 1819 is
that adequate assurance can be provided
in respective councils arrangements for
risk management and internal control and
governance and a general called with
proper practice and a fundamentally
sound this opinion does not imply that
internal is reviewed all risks relating
to the council we only have a fine and
finite number of resources we can't
or did mention month they'll send a
bunch of mine
it's not about specific projects per se
it's about the framework in which we
manage projects and the process that
projects are subject to avoid you know
accomplishing everything with it with
him yeah yeah it's about how we manage
projects should be updated because that
would be historical is permanent so be
sure
project management training that we've
got in place currently so they'll be
auditing what what the arrangements are
for reporting and managing projects and
they will pour that back June it's fine
actually yet so no sorry I may be Robin
is they completely here but if we're
talking about something that is
encompassing all projects within the
scope of accounts if you store a bit
there must be something that comes into
this because I mean you're looking at
it's been internal on page 71 paid
we do it by individuals writing his
aren't yet yep we do this a lot touch
just I'm just doing summary we tend not
to give an assurance writing necessary
assurance writing dose can you clarify I
think because that looks to me like is
something when I read that initially I
thought that must be relative to the
frame house project because there's
nothing been done to for you to look
what they've not not being done that
moment that will be meaning to me but
that gives me the impression that is
something that's completely fresh and
has no bearing on anything historically
but what I sing they where it's not
pickles it was he's got any something
so I think what we're trying to say is
that we haven't formed an insurance
rating at this stage because this Jim
said we've heard the order into this
year so we've done that light touch
review that hasn't been pinpointed any
specific areas of concerns to be worried
about of the month
at the moment but yeah that order is
still being 1920
maybe have the food spenders really the
recommendation is sorry here is just
consolation advice you gave up seven for
two months
like I say that I mean you actually do
we conclude that the white office races
like this one regarding the Cabinet
Office but is all the white to be hints
I take it that's just be adequate take
you've got on there which hopefully
we'll be moving to good one what is
assured of that
well obviously we're always aiming for
not finding work but for good but as you
say we've can't pretend that everything
is perfect at the moment we know there
are some issues with IT but I think with
these are the issues that we are we're
in the report but obviously we're always
striving to do better so yes castleroy
sorry thank you I'm just late so it's
just very quickly just not to make it
clear that patient pointer to the around
the in-house infrastructure
you saying I just want to make you aware
many communities that that's better in
other areas yes correct recommendation
it is proposed when he resolves the
teeth or the it's experts opinion on the
overall adequacy and effectiveness of
the council systems of governance risk
management and internal control be noted
subject to the comments of our comments
raised or degree
I took eight internal audit pan and
charter for 2019-20 that's you again
Mike I think thank you Jim
he yell audit plan himself is
essentially as Cynthia list the board
engaging to be conducted during the
coming year his purpose derive from mine
need to provide an opinion that counsels
arrangements for risk management
internal control of government self no
actual formula exists or can be applied
to determine the minimum level of
coverage into affected individual
factors we read each organisation will
determine priorities that said the UM
the audit plan itself has been developed
by will take an account of the risks
identified by the organization in its
written script register using the
internal auditors its own experience of
the organization and the public sector
more generally discussing all identified
risks with other irrelevant factors with
the organization's management to clarify
the potential scope for internal audit
in terms of planned delivery we have no
resource issues this time around and
hopefully we'll feel completely what a
plan is set out for you the internal
audit Charter is essentially a formal
document defines internal audits a
purpose authority responsibility and our
position between an organization it
effectively acts as a service level
agreement between you and myself the
Charter sets out the name shuttle
services the internal audit will provide
and how internal would it will help the
organization achieve its objectives and
chartering something needs to be
reviewed periodically an approval it
committee especially if any changes
occur thank any question
just go to tools if I may what are the
penalties in regards to anything in
regards to risk 5 on 8.6 me
a lot better when the distribution
issues definitely should there be any
loss of data than the monitoring on
facilitation officer at the world
assessment will make it report to the
information this and they were looking
to they have a power to levy they can be
quiet
it used to be a maximum of five hundred
thousand I think it's up to four percent
of your fellowman things like so it
could be millions of pounds for some
organizations - the holy thank you just
like paint John make Windows here I'm
sorry to bring up on some TV okay it's a
particular home for a brisk contain 23
for the ICT state supportive treatment
of business pain internal do an accent
friend this has the further to this ia
to turn the individual and see a baby
external shores is from relevant to
third parties like the indication of
what we're referring to there what sort
of third parties and independent third
parties or third parties we were
obtaining the point a microphone so I
think we are making reference again so
the fact that we can a commission and I
think federally report in yeah it's also
a relations are things like penetration
test with engaging third party to do
that piece of work for us so that's why
you mentioned that a previous treatment
that's referring to that more than that
maybe further points matter but the
recommendation it is proposed twenty
results that the proposed audit banned
the Charter for 2019-20 be approved
agreement
schedule of business for the Audit
Committee 2019 to 20 this is for noted
only and we still don't know me yes this
was sets out the planned schedule of
work for the Audit Committee over the
next financial year so yeah and there's
no answer any specific questions or
gestures to that world justice use that
then it's thank you
policies contained accounting policies
2018-19 know me thank you so this is
just tonight and a couple of changes to
accounting policies that will be
following in preparing the accounts that
will presented to you at the next
Audient committee and there's a couple
of new accounting standards that are
being introduced from this financial
year and in addition we have taken some
advice and more external value add value
as in terms of our depreciation policy
so that the payment sets out those
technical counts and changes and yet
they are they are technical in nature
but if anyone's got any questions about
why before I know some canister
announcement because grace thank you in
three depreciation
show me the Sun should be something 20
is especially sure there's something
should be something like methodology for
how we determine whether it's 20 or 50
that could make a huge difference
Americans yes I mean it depends on the
type of building is the counter policies
meant to reflect the useful life of the
of the asset so we take external advice
and from our valuers in terms of what
the useful economic life of the asset is
so that's why there's a bit of stroke
wanted to call that entity yeah so it
does mention that that off in the report
but we could maybe try and make that
slightly clearer in the actual policy
changer Holly
thank you Joe return at this time well
but I've never asked to be in this
overheating when we have their own
accounts presented to us by the next
meeting Bothell WA spelled the the
counselor analysis and buried in the
financial statements normally and their
about page 66 of the legislators or
who's going next and very dubious lead
doesn't the only it's appropriate it
says they need to be presented but I
think they we should have a think about
maybe it was a little more openly that's
further down the report
I mean it yeah in terms of ordering
either not Robards the right word it's
just a huge amount of information we
have to prepare anyhow this huge number
of different notes and yeah you're the
ordering of them obviously there's some
ordering that we have to follow in terms
of also having the primary statements
first and then and then the notes
traditionally sort of follow in
numerical order to refer to the specific
bits and the primary statements so yeah
I mean it's something we could
potentially look at in terms of how we
would present the accounts and I accept
their prints the principle that we want
to be as clear and transparent and
actually something that and ey are
recommending and generally across all
authorities is sort of revisiting the
formatting of the counts and actually
trying to take out notes where they're
not material and actually reduce the
volume of the accounts themselves to
make them easier to read so I I accept
the principle in point I don't think
there's any specific sort of you know
writing place where that we need your
notes are in the accounts and now they
are they are transparent and available
in the place of the account so we're not
trying to bury them it's just it's just
that there's a huge amount of
information being to be included within
those Thank You Jared I just like to
know where was the source of the new
policy when that new policy come
so the accounting policies is something
we review every year just to make sure
they're up to date in line with best
practice and new accounting standards so
there's two specific areas that referred
to in the report so why are fast IFRS 9
is a new requirement on local
authorities for this financial year in
terms of power we classify financial
instruments it doesn't have a huge
bearing on lastest accounting because we
haven't actually got a huge amount of
complexity in terms of the money that we
invest the depreciation as I say it's
been driven from the conversations or
external valuers to ensure that we
actually valuing our assets in line with
a small economic life which is again
accounting best practice so it's in line
with the city for code which is that
basically our Viral of how we should
prepare the accounts it would be useful
possibly if there was an asterism
against these just to say where the
source awesome okay I think well yeah
this is just where's the sauce so I
think I think it doesn't try to make
that clear in in the report but and yeah
if they're specific and things we can
try my clear again we can we can try and
my office be careful man see they're
modified challenging
you have to do that microphone to
referring back to very serious policy
challenges yeah yeah but it's aa really
like it if I may
it just it seems to me there's a new
policy challenge when does that pose who
eats tonight from sorry then what was do
you know is that always pick a language
yeah you don't just walk straight
through the chair through for changes
you okay yeah yeah I suppose we brought
this back to you to be as transparent
about that as possible perhaps in the
past we haven't necessarily mean as
upfront and transparent to say where
there have been accounts of policies
because are quite technical in nature
and but a external auditors and again do
have to approve where we've made changes
to accounting policies to make sure that
they're happy that they are in line with
best practice so I think that the
strings all we're doing here is agent
wills division later yeah yeah I accept
there's a bit of a balance isn't that
between what the the point we just made
about the complexity and the length of
the accounts and and the relevance of
what we include in this so the more
information we include the longer they
get so I thought that that balance has
to be strong
cancel new data say that they face
probably less either assume yourself but
you leave my surprise just to put them
yeah yeah but your now we can add a fit
night into the accounts just any further
point recommendation its proposed of the
committee results of accounting policies
be approved for inclusion in the annual
financial report subject to the points
made and recommended
with only a high-level view of the
council's risk management framework and
the corporate risk register that me I
think yeah thank chair so this report is
to present the updates the council's
risk management policy and framework for
1924 members consideration and approval
and it also incorporates the latest
version of the corporate risk register
which members will be aware is updates
from six monthly basis and brought back
to this committee New York through your
review
so you've previously been cited on the
risk register and in November 2018 so
the risk management policy and framework
is not fundamentally changed we've added
some new updates around the processes of
contract risk registers and yeah
the changes are highlighted within the
report but also drawing attention to
that we've had a strategic risk
management review by an external partner
which is one of the council's and
insurers Zurich and the details of that
risk review and the recommendations and
VBAC are also incorporated in into the
report and
so yet members are asked to approve the
updating policy and framework for 1920
and to approve the content of the
corporate risk register so if anyone's
got any questions questions right it is
recommend
proposed 20 results to prove the
updating number one to improve the
updating risk management policy and
framework
number two to improve the content of the
corporate risk register through the 2019
20 government Audit Committee breathing
you know okay yeah so I get music we
were quietly there this was just to note
an essay no one's quite nice to make
questions it's something that Ernst &
Young asked us to circulate some members
it's for your information and just give
you some background in terms of the
issues that audit committees might want
to be aware of and that again was a
plain stone written great detailing
anyone an essay was very specific yeah
giving something's being revealed
with